FCDC
PAINTSTRCTIS.
IF YOUCCINAT
N EXTRAORDINY
G HO
LKG OU T% S SURVIVINANKS
LET'S BRING IN OURIT
HARRY, FIRST, COULD DS FOR US?
YOU'REHOSE A
YO CHANCR SURVIVING ANEA
LOOK 160AMERS
NOR00
AND WHAT I'M INTERESTED IN IMPEL
TOD, AND WR
UNE OF DYING IS 25ER
VACCINATED T T U HAVET GO O
THE NUMBERS PAINT A CLCTURE.
>> RIGHT.
I MEAN, THATAT T NUMBERSJU-
WH D R
IT'S, IN FT, ICCINATPOIN SS
OPSIE WAS AN AXIOSDOTOWARD THEDD
AMCC ADULTD ABOUT TH
SHOULD BE BF ASON WHY THESE UAE
AFRAID.
THEY SHOULD BE AFRAIAN
INOUD TTG VAINVAIN
WH
VIRUS.SK OF SICK A THE
WHUT MWE
SEEIIT
T.
IFT GOING TOAT,
RIGHT?RING A
SHOS THE DATAHONG
UNVAATED FOLNE
GAC DOING%  UNVACCINATEG  WHEN
THAT ISIHE PERCENTAGE OFINEDARTH
, L NUTTER.
IT MAKES NO SENS PEOPLE FIRSOF
D AT LEAST
OF THEM 'R
N LEAV
IT'S MIN
IT.
THNU
PERSUASIVE.
G MEOWCY MIC
INEWEREE
NOT DIEOUE EOPLE CE
AS SOMEONEHOATED ANDS INTE WHEA.
OF.AEN TAKE CARE
S THERE ARESYMPTOMS,
SIT OF THAISF
VACCINATION IN OUR STATEND
OMVER ANE CA VACCIHLY
PROTECTIVE FOROTECTIVE FOR THOSL
SECAE OW ID  W
WESE TO SCHOOL
GOING TT E THERE
TOE OUTBAK
THIS IS INBE
PEOPLE AREN'T REALLY AS FOCUSSED
BE. NT PROTECTINGSE.ROTECTING E
PELEE VACCINS  RIGHT, ANY OF T
THESE ARE OUR CHDR
T RISK BECAUSEVACCINATEDE WARNGH
OU T
SEE  HAVENOUGHTHPERCENTAGE OF PS
BUE ENOUGHOT U ITHE N  W LAS
WINTER.
BUWORSE.RE
THIS IS ADAT THE TREND LES
N TH OR IFO BACK TO MARCH, THE S
AND TALKTOOTHER ATESEYY
WITHIN APLLKDEAL TRANSFERRING P
OU
THAT'S NOT JUST ADULERE'S NO PEI
IF A K GS REALLYICERE'S ER
AND THEY'RE GOING TO SEEUIORIDA
DEATHS BECAUSE OF THE LACK ORES
CASES COMING NOT JUST T HOW LET
TH REDUCED RESOURCES
TH BE
EI.
N ON THE HEALTH CARE
'S REPUBCA
GOS ACCUSING UHEALTH
OF, QUOTE, EN,GIHTFUL HI
BESHLYS TO THE TONE  HOW
DIFFERENT IS.
WE SHOD  IS
OPLE TT  Y -
OUOF PROPORTION?
NTOMS.HIS WORKS. HE'S PUSHING NR
CCATT IT'S NOT A EVERYLING YOU
KIG E ISINRM
WHOLE WAY THROUGH, ANDT'GETTING.
BECAUSE IT'SD FOR O
IT'S SDIASW WHAT O E DELTA VARIS
NTS IT COULD BE MORELETHAL.
AND EN IF TH
ISN'ITAVE,T
AND LOT INDIA ANKINGDOT A GO, AK
ABSCIENCE, IT'ABSOLUTELY
EMBA TO BE
REALUT IDEAS OUT THAT ARERANKLYU
EXPLAINED, WHY IT'S SODIFFS SO.
DOCTOR FRANCIS CLI
DIRECTOR
EANGS
IN
VACCINATED. IOR TMOIN.E GOTTEN
R THINGS THA
>> IURE THER
K TO AS
I THINTH F
NOT IT'S Y
SSWES
VACCINATED.RECTLG  REQEVERYBWHRK
I IND SOINMORES POSIVE
ARE THIS THEOR THE CTSE REWARDG
ITLL THERE.YTNGO GET
T,UTT'TIME FORS TO ADD O WCONGTT
DECISION JUTOU
MAKING A PERSONASION TT OTHERS H
YOU'RE CHOOSING
VACCNG TY
HISIMILA POKATY TO